Rick toet says Garling can be a buzz saw
on that line and Matt Coronado he's having
himself an exhibition year third in the NHL
in scoring with four goals and seven points
trailing only Jesper Brad and Jack Hughes
he wasn't there to pick up the bank pass
from besser and the puck is down the
ice quick up from Demco here's Miller
and DJ sepi trying to move in drop
pass Meyers shoots he scores [Music]
69 seconds into the game Tyler Myers makes it one-
nothing a better start for his team and this is
what he envisioned DJI gets into the Zone protects
the puck long enough Miller fights off a check and
right at the front of the net besser providing the
screen Meyers with the rer and one nothing early
for the Canucks and Teddy bler clears The Zone 40
seconds to the Susi penal there's a hit by julson
along the sideboards flams maintain control pass
to cornado shoots up high backin keeps the puck in
feeds it back to the line that could have been
dangerous bler was lurking now the pass to the
side of the goal du looking across Dylan du Cuts
in front hit the post trying to go short side on
Demco but the puck stayed out Hanahan 15 seconds
to go on the p Power Play cornado Noah Han shot
hoping for a tip du couldn't make contact Flames
came close on the power play du off the post still
one enough on that man Advantage although du
came close hitting the post behind enco tried
to go near side but the K didn't chase here's Dr
hunting he hadit some room on the short side but
Demco was able to hold it out as I did with the
penalty killing numbers here's a Patterson shot
right off the Hop rebound loose power play if you
want to face off get it to the net here's a one
timer that isn't handled cleanly marks from spits
out the rebound this shot from Pon hit besser and
it SCS three to Jon tried to find Susi but it went
right past him Flames look to take advantage Puck
is centered hubero tees it up in front weer missed
the net now huo the Side Diving back was Demco and
it's in I think I think it wound up over the
goal line and it'll be huberto goal I believe
as Calgary's tied it at one Cadre there as well
poking away and it was a missed pass behind the
net that caused all the confusion for the Canucks
then they got chasing around herberto the spin
pass and as Demco gets across to the side did it
go in before Cadre got it or did codre ultimately
put it over the line it's still hugging the red
until Cadre came in in the celebration as I think
91 lies in action across the street in a big
game here it's 1-1 and we're set to go in the
middle frame Flames control that drum pson
a little frustrated after he went to the ice
and got back up Coronado pressured by Garland
ponic moves down aggressively from the right
Point Pon stands up his man weager and now
here's Anderson ahead to cornado he's got a
step on Garland Matt cornado in with a r shot
high and wide Hughes chops to the puck backin
intercepts in the corner Cole takes a look
passes one across too hot to handle for Omar
but a good read There by Cole to keep the puck
in in front bler is stopped by marer who's able
to cover the puck line to keep the puck in find
the open man but markstrom with the right pass
Christopher TANF starts from behind his net gave
it away here's Miller kicked out by Mar can happen
and there's besser tips the shot Miller gets a
lot off it quickly and it's the left pad save
Tan's pass was tipped and it turned into a clean
giveaway now the Flames a chance for a two-on-one
sushi attempting to break it up here's cornado
to the net didn't get much on it and Denco got
with the left pth hunt turns and sends the puck
behind the Canuck goal Hughes is out with it qu
Hughes had it knocked off his stick but he gets
it right back up the middle here's bler digs he
scores move by bler and this is why Quinn PES
can do so well no options skate up there's an
option and that little backand and the soft
touch between the pads markstrom stretches
out he was guessing on the blocker side as
Hughes threads the needle this just touches
the back of the net and then some collateral
damage at the net pass to heroni takes it on
the backand shovels the puck down to Pon 25
seconds go on the power play kmco back pass
for Miller drops back to heroni who keeps the
puck in 420 left in the second here's pon across
for besser gloves it down feeds it to heroni
down to Pon Miller to Pon again 5 Seconds to
go on the power play besser takes a look kicked
out by Marr nice save there moving to his left
and trailing the right pad and now the penalty
to hunt is over in the Canucks Areo for three
besser was able to get that shot underneath
the defenseman Hanahan who's trying to block
it so it stays two- on Vancouver as
the conu break up ice here's movila
up the middle R shot Walker saved by Marr
and he's able to steer that one over the
Glass Long pass ahead TI through by Phil
D jppy we're in the final minute of the
second KX leading Calgary 2 to one pu held
in by Patterson now in front TJ all the L
scores a goal in the final minute of the second as
Puck found its way in front to Phil dppi and it's
3-1 Canucks what a wonderful play by besser as it
looks like the Puck's going to get by him there's
the Finish but it's off his skates kept alive
and besser puts it to an area DJ sepi is just
fit in so well relatively injuryf free preseason
for the Canucks which is a departure from years
past and they'll hope that Susi can be back in the
lineup soon but he will not return to this game
here tonight here's a chance in front and corn
outed much on that shot which fluttered wide of
the goal leas patteron chips the puck ahead Kenco
couldn't move it in but now heroni will drive the
pucking off the [Applause] glass kanuck set it up
for besser with a shot and that sounded like it
went off the knob of the goal stick of Jacob
marstrom start their change they're off here
but DJI and besser are headed to the bench anyway
here's du to Anderson puts one in front oh what a
save by Demco his best of the game as he denied
nasam cadri on that cross ice pass from Rasmus
Anderson dco lunging to his right got the
right pad on the tap in try from Cadre now
stanica steals at the blue L bler pass broken
up and weager brings the Pucket H check from
behind by Oman he's got a step on the left wing
nobody's with him neels Oman R shot and markm had
the short side cover then he gave Oman a little
shot as the conu forward skated past the goal
crease Andre Kenco Off the Bench into the
Calgary Zone pass through patteron back
to kzco he turns with the puck turns
again in the corner puts it in front
Pon couldn't steer it behind markster earlier
and that one from Dakota Joshua As Time winds
out on this one one last bit for the empty
net and the Canucks finish the pre-season